how do we overcome
trauma what are the different Pathways
the first thing the very first thing is
to acknowledge to ourselves and often to
others which might be one other person
it might be in words spoken it might be
written like what the trauma has been
right because the the lessons of trauma
the evil lessons of trauma and I'll use
the example of my own life the lesson
that told me that I was shameful uh
cursed and hopeless right
it's a very evil lesson right but my
brain will say it over and did say it
over and over and over to me and if that
just sits inside that's how trauma
festers that's how trauma hijacks our
thoughts our emotions so being able to
say to ourselves and to another like
this is what's happened right okay this
is what's happened we're built to
massage words and to create meaning
through words right like we don't
massage pictures write images we talk
and massage meaning with words so if so
when I finally went to see a therapist
and I and I could say you know
my brother whatever words I would have
said like he he killed himself and I and
I I can't
accept it or I can't imagine it and like
I let it happen like so I had to say
those things right so then I could begin
to bring some sense of of truth to it
you know and I think it was a long time
ago but the therapist probably said
something like okay probably sees on you
it's you let it happen it's your fault
right because you got to get at those
things so that so that one can begin to
bring into Focus what does the trauma
mean and what does it not mean I mean a
classic example is it is that what would
you say to someone else example you know
he'll say well I now how many times have
I it's just I cry if I stop and think
about it if you stop and talk to someone
who is sexually assaulted through no
fault of their own who comes in and
tells the story they've been telling
themselves about how it's their fault
they should have walked home a different
way they should address differently they
should have left earlier right I wrote
about it in the book over and over and
over now you have a person who let's say
you take a person who's intelligent
engage in the world who's like capable
of understanding lots and lots and lots
of things but doesn't understand that
right if it were someone else that
person would understand in a moment
that's not that person's fault right so
so what you want to do is overcome the
fact that the negative emotions that the
the hijacked emotion systems of trauma
are telling that person a lie and
they're telling them so strongly and so
awfully so meanly that the person just
takes it inside and starts to see it as
true right so you begin to hold that up
to the light of day and again one
example could be okay so someone my
person who's coming in next has actually
been through something similar right and
can do you mind can you stay and just
tell her how it's her fault right and
like oh my God no because I could never
like then they see right and again I'm
not this is not always how you do it but
sometimes you can get a person to see
like well that would be the most
horrible
how could you do that right the person
can maybe commit they're doing it to
themselves so so you know you you begin
you begin to put words in a structure
and say okay look let's look at what's
going on inside of you like you have to
be scared of anything you're thinking
and feeling in fact the fear is in not
exposing it to the light to the light of
day that's where it gets the best of us
and now like everything is different and
whether that involves use of medications
for intrusive thoughts and and
depression or there's no medicines
needed but it's all reframing like
whatever it may be that comes next the
whole world has changed when the person
has acknowledge what's happened exposed
it to the to themselves and to trusted
others around them and begun to look at
it in some way other than the stuff in
an evil box place that the trauma
initially puts us through our the
reflexes it creates in us it's
interesting that there's power to just
saying it out loud right so first saying
your perception of it out loud
other in that case that might be your
fault and then working through out loud
working through
that it may not be
any experienced therapist will tell you
will tell you this that every now and
then it will happen that someone will
come and and they'll say something
usually it's very early on in the
process they'll say something they've
never said before and they immediately
are are like in an entirely different
place and they may have been for decades
right and I can remember a person saying
that the the a coach had raped him and
just saying it this was decades before
and everything was different I'm not
saying everything is now is perfect but
his life was in a different but as soon
as he said it he could see how dare like
he thought that person did that to this
child the child was me he'd never
thought it until he said it out loud
because his mind was going over and over
with why it was his fault what he did to
deserve it how he kept going back so it
must be his fault it was in it as soon
as he put words to it he saw the truth
of it and you lose a bifurcation in the
path of life then and any therapist has
had you know stories like that which
just shows the immense power that it it
can even be that just uttering the words
makes just a Cascade of change all at
once
this is saying those words to another
human being
uh yeah it makes you wonder about that
compulsive Loop that happens in our
heads right uh until it's brought to the
surface it's so interesting entirely
non-productive loops and sometimes even
if we put what would I say to another
let me write it down it can get rid of
those Loops in our in our brains any
even thought of outward expression is
the enemy of those internal persecutory
negative thought loops